2んはぁっ
はぁっ
はいこんにちははじめ手帳ですというかみなさん覚えてますでしょうか
ちょっと結構前にもう1個家がありますという話をしたんですけどもうあの良いよ
今日を持つましてねこの部屋はずにアミューズメントパークでの殺0
いやしないこともないですねしますますけど基本的な作例が完全に別の家に変わること
になりました
[音楽]
とりあえずすぐ移動しましょう
go
んはぁっあんっ
ません
うわぁ
ああああああ
[音楽]
わー
ガーズレこの新しいくれた部屋あること1個はすべて外れシャツをチャンネルためだけ
になります
痩せのようやく引っ越しすることができました
ちょっと言えるを持っていこうちょっと照明灯がように思っています
寧
ございます
正面さやなんとかなるみたいなとこある人昔も見せしたと思うしてもこれで完全移行で
ございますその2燃えてないんですけどこの家で外れシャツをメインなさん出る言葉を
出していこうと思っております
はい的なにこの日を借りたかっていうと
説明をちゃんとさせていただきますそんな難しい話じゃないんですけども今始めたと畑
っていう
俺の周りの友達とか後輩とかいろんな人を巻き込んで by はやってるチャンネルが
あるんですけどその実やるし
そもそも前から国うんちはずみゅーずめんとパークに
下のデイリーがめちゃくちゃ今激しくなってしまいました
もうほんと常にいる後輩とかも良いですし毎日のように来る奴もいるし
1日56人は必ずあの家に人が来ます f 組約カード嬉しいし
もともと
実を言うとの勇気をやるまで月のもっつだったんですよ持つキャラならね本当のぼっち
で行ったんですけど
指を始めてからいろんな人とアップまだ人が増えて
まあ鉄球それでもカードを通さないとコミュニケーションできないってことなんですよ
ね
まあこういう問いでカードでもかんでも体があってすごいいろんな頭が近くへたり
いろんな人と話せるようになって本当にいいましょう俺はリア充だ
友達いっぱいえって感じでずっとやってきたんですけど
me
よく考えるとよく考えるとあの僕は一人が好きなんだなってことに気づいてしまいまし
たみんなでワイワイしてるのがやっているじゃないんですよそれはそれで楽しいんです
皆デバイスを楽しいんですよ
それを叩きのチャンネルでそれは ok 浦添でおいといてじゃあこの数利社長の
チャンネル和美社長のチャンネルメインはどうするのかといいますと
あの北
一人じゃないと実は動画撮れない人間なんですよ
このことができるかテレビで撮ったりこれは落ちたりとかすれば別なんですけど
恥ずかしくて後にじゃないと実は動画が撮れないんです分かれていませんこの関税
なかったよく考えてくださりよだれかみてるとしましょう誰か見てたり友達とかもいる
中ですっ
上手じゃ発車だよって大
ああああああ
ってやると
惹かれるんですよもしこれを誰か見てるとどういうリアクションっていうのは分から
ない犬な空気になっちゃうのがすごいよねー
恥ずかしいですよそんな1人だて眠れ
やるんですけどこのおっ誰から見てるとなるとそんなを恥ずかしくてとてもじゃない
ところができない
できるはずですね気ないんだよ素走り車窓のチャンネルてもと
というか一人で今ならやるチャンネルだったねこれがちょっとあまゆにゃ人が多すぎて
めちゃくちゃやりづらいなと思っていたんで
今回のぼっちで戻りというわけではないんですけどひとりで暴れ放題の子のお家でこの
所狩りで再びやっていこうというわけでございました感じだというと思うんですけど
若干5型ちょっとおとなしめになったと思うんですよ
なぜかというと家に人が入って恥ずかしかったからですとてもじゃないんですけど
ran
が全然できませんからね恥ずかしいじゃないですか犬と思われちゃそんなのために見
られへんって思われちゃうそんなのいや何で辺で追われるのが嫌で恥ずかしってとこ
あの人が増えてからかなり抑えていた部分はあったと思いますまあ取り上げてこんな
強羅この完全に1人まあコラボとなドッキリとか全然人と一緒にてますけどベージュの
本堂や一人で打っちゃ
誰なんでここね自分なして恥ずかしたのか謎ねー
いまオレ何だってできるそう俺は古木で最高のボッツなんです
[音楽]
me
me あった